بحلول الوقت د.  وصل كامينو بيل
إلى الأريكة لمشاهدة التلفزيون مع فتياته الثلاث
، وقد قضى بالفعل يومًا كاملاً في
غرفة الطوارئ في
المركز الطبي لجامعة هاكنساك في نيوجيرسي
مثل غيره من المرضى في جميع أنحاء البلاد في الوقت
الحالي معظم المرضى الذين يعالجهم
لديهم  فيروس كورونا كان حجم
المرضى المصابين بأمراض خطيرة غير مسبوق
بكفالة تزدهر في
الأيام المليئة بالضغوط الشديدة التي يجلبها هذا الوباء
قبل أن يرتدي الزي الرسمي الذي
كان يرتدي قميص كرة القدم الذي لعبه بيل
في جامعة إلينوي
وتم تجنيده لاحقًا إلى فريق Miami
Dolphins.  النكات ، أصبح في النهاية
قرارًا سهلاً بترك كرة القدم ، لقد تم قطع كرة القدم
ثلاث مرات ، حيث سعى وراء مهنة في
الطب ،
يقول زملاؤه الآن الأطباء والممرضات الذين
يكافحون هذا المرض ،
تقول Hackensack Medical إنها شاهدت أكثر
من 2000 Kovac 19 مريضًا
منذ أن بدأ الوباء.
أنت عندما يشبهونني ثم
لم تكن هناك مشاكل طبية أخرى وبعد
ذلك أرى أنك تعرف مدى
حرجتهم ثم أنا  يمكن أن يحدث
لأي شخص اقترب من حدوثه
له في وقت سابق من هذا العام ، عالج بيل
مريضًا ثبتت إصابته لاحقًا
بكوبان 19 ، وقد تم عزله في
قبو منزله بعيدًا عن عائلته لمدة أسبوع
ولكنه لم يصاب بالفيروس الآن
الطابق السفلي هو المكان الذي يذهب إليه بعد كل
وردية قبل أن أتمكن من رؤية الأسرة التي يجب
أن آتي بها إلى هنا وتطهير
الوظيفة تأتي مع مخاطر جسيمة
.  احتفل به الغرباء وزملائه السابقون لعمله
في الخطوط الأمامية
مثل الفائز مرتين في
سوبر بول هوارد جريفيث
كل يوم يغادر المنزل
ليخرج ويساعد الغرباء
ويستمر في احتضان ذلك وهذا
حقًا هو من لديه  كان
طوال حياته يريد دائمًا مساعدة
الآخرين في
تحفيز الهتافات لبيل وهو يقاتل
أعتى خصومه حتى الآن مع العشب المهدب سي إن إن
هاكنساك نيو جيرسي